donc l'un de ces tunnels mène à l'
arbre à troll c'est vrai tellement beaucoup d'entre eux
je me demande lequel je ne sais pas
choisir un trou yz4 un muli à bergen
ville et les autres mm qui ont dit que
moi hey les gars comment ça va je voulais juste
pour t'avertir un de ces tunnels mène
à l'arbre à troll et les autres à
une mort certaine mort
tu penses pouvoir nous dire lequel est
le bon
tu paries super non ça va on va bien
merci francha il essaie de nous aider je
je n'aime pas son apparence il a l'air de
savoir de quoi il parle d'
accord très bien dans quelle direction allons-nous d'abord tu
dois me donner un high five alors je
te dirai que je ne fais pas de high fives gifle le
patron
ne va pas  arrive ici fais juste ça mais
avec ta main merci pour cette
démonstration vraiment éclairci exactement
ce que je ne ferai pas riche c'est un
high five les autres mènent à une
mort certaine obtenez une perspective d'accord
ne vous laissez pas glisser avec un coup de poing whoop
attaque de requin  non non non non main de méduse
Sam avec des dindes bonhomme de neige faire  pas alors
hélicoptère c'est supérieur chanceux le zoo
quel est ton quart de travail d'
accord d'accord d'accord maintenant je pense que nous nous étreignons